good afternoon and welcome to the Spirit
Awards first of all I just want to say
thank you to IFP West for asking me to
emcee this because I started as you know
with a small film called Hollywood
shuffle with the Samuel Goldwyn company
and a credit card that I charge to the
max today I'm really excited because
[Music]
there were a lot of great films last
year a lot of films that were made with
a lot of courage Robert Rodriguez made a
film for $7,000 incredible incredible a
lot of great films last year Robert
Altman's short cuts one of my favorite
actors turned director and came out with
an incredible film mr. John Turturro
with Mack but I think my favorite film
last year had to be much ado about
nothing
and I don't know it's just you know the
film made me laugh it was some
incredible acting and it inspired me
because my next film the next film that
I'm working on is Julius Caesar no I'm
gonna do Julius Caesar and I'm going to
do it with well if this afternoon I mean
if you'd like to see a few scenes from
it I could do a few scenes from my new
film if you if you guys like to see it
here's a few scenes from Julius Caesar
as done by the all black and Hispanic
Shakespearean company The Ides of March
are here and I pray that Caesar may live
to see another day
oh those treacherous traitors that have
tried to kill my lord Caesar I pray that
he Hawk who goes there who goes there
it be and My lordy be I put that sword
away before you hurt somebody and it
ain't gonna be me
I pray you what news of Caesar what news
of Caesar that's what I came to tell you
my lord they killed by Caesar downtown
they took his walkman and everything he
was just walking down the street with
his man on his money and his money on
his man Laidback come let us go to Rome
and I shall speak to the citizens of
Rome come let us go to Rome
healthy butter chariot go chariot
chariot chariot I see your ass in Rome
Punk Marc Anthony Mark Anthony Mark
Anthony Mark Anthony Mark Anthony Mark
Anthony who needs
who needs tickets who needs tickets who
needs tickets
who needs tickets Marc Anthony citizens
of railroad I come not to bury Caesar
but to praise him for Brutus is an
honorable man so are they all all
honorable men I speak not to disprove
Brutus and the killers Brutus and the
killers Brutus and the killers
ladies and gentlemen that number one
group that's been rocking Rome Brutus
and the killer
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen The Killers I kill
CGG Jesus he got in my way
stabbed him in the back what did I say
power control of rule would be man
that's all the time we have coming to a
theater near you soon
it was a joke it's amazing he's really
gonna do that
who's distributing it as mayor max got
that oh I don't know I didn't hear
Thomson was doing that ladies and
gentlemen the man who created much to do
about nothing to present the first award
mr. Kenneth Branagh
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much very nice very nice
indeed to be here I'm very honored as an
independent without a major studios
financial help or guarantee of
distribution there is no greater task in
filmmaking I think than the initiation
of your first feature film requires
extraordinary patience and perseverance
stamina for rejection and most
importantly an enduring love and
commitment to your chosen story the
nominations for the best first feature
film our american heart director martin
bell combination platter director Tony
Chan
el Mariachi director Robert Rodriguez
Mack director John Turturro
and menace to society directors Albert
and Allen huge and the winner is El
Mariachi
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh God I would have prepared a speech
that I thought you would give this to me
now you're gonna pay oh I you know I
feel really almost embarrassed to even
be up here cuz I try to bury this movie
when it first was suggested to be put in
theaters in fact wow that's such an odd
an odd moment I guess it's only
appropriate this being independent
Awards that I think of all people a
Hollywood studio Columbia Pictures
because if it wasn't for them you never
would have seen it because when they
first bought my tape I didn't even have
a film print they bought it off a VHS
tape they said um you know instead of
remaking it which is why they bought it
we didn't like it the way it is why
don't we put it in some theaters and see
if people's luck I said no not this one
about if I know people are gonna see it
I would have done so many things
different I mean in fact if you're gonna
go to all the expense of making a film
print blowing it up and advertising it
let me reshoot some of it I mean I just
know when people see it I changed some
things I would give me a week in two
thousand dollars or we shoot half of it
Hey
they didn't even they said no we don't
want to spend the money well we'll see
how it will see how it plays like this
and then if people want to change the
ending or whatever then well maybe let
you go reshoot some today they don't
like the speech very much they're
falling down at the tables they they
decided to put it out like that people
enjoyed it and ended up being the first
movie released by major studio in
Spanish and shot independently like this
so it's a great inspiration for the IP
to give a word like this to an aspiring
filmmaker like myself because it and
it's good for other aspiring filmmakers
right about now or about to hit the
grandparents up for a couple hundred
thousand dollars to make the breakout
film
maybe they'll rethink that and say you
know what it really isn't the wallet
that makes the movie
it's your creativity your passion your
hard work
well you guys know that already but I
mean money sometimes kills creativity
and anybody anybody can tap themselves
out financially making it movie that's
not the idea
it's a tap yourselves out creatively
first and you've inspired me to go on in
a town that is usually very uninspiring
tonight you have inspired and I thank
you for that and one last thing to my
beautiful wonderful sweet loving wife
Elizabeth you know this really belongs
to you and I'll hand it over as soon as
I get back to the table Oh
if you wondering what I'm going to do
now that I have probably about seven
million dollar budget on my next movie
well the idea is to stay creative and
hard so I'm going to shoot the movie for
7,000 give the rest to charity because
the studio will never know the
difference anyway
[Music]
now please welcome James Lacroix and
Laura San Giacomo
[Music]
writers are the storytellers of our time
they give us a mirror of our lives
screenplays are stories written for a
cinematic medium sometimes adapted from
literature news or inspired by our own
memories and life experiences for Best
Screenplay the nominees are Robert
Altman and Frank bar height shortcuts
[Applause]
Edwin Baker and Tony Chan combination
platter Angley kneel pang and James
Sheamus the wedding banquet
Victor Nunez Ruby in paradise
[Applause]
Nancy Sobotka and Richard gray household
stains and the winner is Robert Altman
and Frank farmer
[Applause]
[Music]
no children I can use some cheering to
see you have a nice day on behalf of the
other guy who worked on this who isn't
here tonight we thank you and I would
like to thank him especially Robert
Altman for choosing me I'd like to thank
thank the late Raymond Carver whose
stories we used I would like to thank
all of the cast who sort of glorified
this and made it come to life I'd like
to thank Carey Brokaw Scott Bushnell IRA
Deutsch Minh at fine line and finally
Tess Gallagher who was Carver's Widow
and was very very helpful to us in this
collaboration thank you very much
[Music]
[Applause]
Debbie Mazur and Bill Paxton
[Music]
a great cinematographer can use the most
elusive medium light to create the most
specific moods and emotions it's great
to be here today to honor and celebrate
the best and independent filmmaking is
my pleasure to Co present the award for
this year's best cinematography and the
nominees are James our begged honest
American heart
Elliot Davis equinox
Lisa Rinzler menace to society
[Applause]
Nancy Schreiber chain of desire Alex
black OHS Ruby and paradise and the
winner is Lisa Rinzler menace to society
[Applause]
in London ladies and gentlemen the
president of production at the Samuel
Goldwyn company and IFP West board
member mr. Tom Rothman Brian green Brown
had already produced metropolitan and
poison when he died at 30 of AIDS
in his memory the IFP honor such Hanzel
and producers while paying homage to the
members of the independent filmmaking
community who have been lost aids the
Brian Greene brown award is given to an
outstanding producer who despite limited
resources which probably applies to most
people helped create a body of
distinctive independent feature films
this year the award is going plural in a
big way
James Seamus and Ted Hope the dual
carbonated engine that drives good
machine production company are
responsible for an almost overwhelming
array of against the odds movies either
separately or together sometimes as
producer executive producer sales rep
writer distributor cheerleader chief
cook and bottle washer they have been
connected with many of the most daring
and difficult to independent films of
the 90s to catalog all their various
achievements or list all their Golden
Globes golden bears golden horses golden
asses I don't know would take longer
than even this program as you may
suspect already the longest lunch in
Hollywood could bear suffice it to say
that among the over 20 films which have
benefited from their unique brand of
Kendu ism are numbered the wedding
banquet the hours and times clean shaven
river
Grass unbelievable truth trust simple
men what happened was swoon thank you
and good night in the soup and the
forthcoming safe amateur and eat drink
man woman even more telling is the list
of directors who whose first or early
films they have fought for believed in
and gotten made Angley Hal Hartley Tom
Noonan Tom Kalin
Jill God milho Todd Haynes Alex Rockwell
Claire Denis and others still it is this
kind of unwavering support for
unconventional filmmakers that
eventually makes possible the truly
great directing directing careers like
today's Cassavetes winter I like to
think that an award to Ted and James is
for everybody sitting with Bob Uecker
way in the back these two guys are
living proof that if you want to you can
get here from there it doesn't take a
ton of money or a three-picture deal
it takes the rare qualities that they
both possess in abundance taste honesty
integrity energy talents talent tenacity
and defiance I think defiance above all
they never make the easy ones and they
never quit they know that people don't
care how much your movie costs they care
how it makes them feel imagine after
hustling for years to make a seemingly
unpickable half English half time
weenies half straight half gay movie
with an unknown director how sweet it
must be to open variety one day and read
the article showing that on a percentage
basis Jurassic Park was actually only
the second most commercially successful
film in the world in 1993 the banner
headline in classic variety metaphor
announced the first banquet eats dinos
lunch
defiance so on behalf for the board of
directors of the IFP and James without
having resorted to a single bowtie joke
it is a pleasure to present this year's
Bryan green bound producing award to the
WWF
Tag Team Champions of lower Manhattan
the good guys from good machine Ted
hope springs eternal and professor James
Sheamus
[Music]
thank you I'm thrilled that the IFP
chose to honor James and I for our
producing efforts I know it's really
just semantics but in the films that
James and I have done together whether
together apart it wasn't us who really
produced these films it's it's been the
support and sacrifices of the cast and
crew in the community around us who have
made the movies independent has meant an
exact opposite of being alone are
separate for us it's been the the
opening openness the willingness to
share information ideas and criticism
that have turned our projects into the
films that they are I really believe
it's it's it's how you work that's more
important than what you make and I hope
you can see all the fun and help we had
in the films we made thank you
particularly proud of either like all
your best friends who worked on the film
people always say I'm able to make the
movie because I called in all my favors
Ted and I have been calling in favors
for over three years now that nobody my
mom and father and stepparents some of
whom were here today and to the family
also to a couple of producers who have
really been guiding lights to us
Christine Vashon first at apparatus
and then a number of companies that she
incorporates with great regularity to
make her films I'm happy to be working
for her - Jim Stark who taught us a lot
of the tricks of the trade and continues
to astonish us with his intelligence and
vigour in pursuing all of our goals and
finally to a particular producer when
first came to know as a voice over a
bunch of cassettes that were mailed as
letters from Berlin in the early 80s
before he was a producer there was a
voice on a friend of mine who used to
send these letters back from Berlin to
New York and there was always this
grating obnoxious incredibly intelligent
wonderful discovering voice that started
to pick a fight with my best friend in
New York Casey Finch who would get these
tapes and start making more tapes back
and start yelling back and it they
carried on for a year without ever
seeing each other
one of the most vituperative intelligent
funny bittersweet hysterical romances
I've ever known and I was surprised a
few years later when I came to New York
to find the person who owned that voice
that was coming at me from Berlin over
all those years I had the great honour
to share my first producing credit as an
executive producer on poison with that
colleague and gentleman and astonishing
very bitchy gossip he went on to make a
lot of wonderful films we were able to
work with him on his very last film he
used to rollerblade and the good machine
offices for meetings in shorts and a
cutoff t-shirt covered with Kaposi
sarcoma with a kind of wonderful up
years to the world he basically left
this world I would say with that kind of
attitude the most ridiculous a dignified
person I've ever known ever to depart in
my world and it's in his honors and the
honor of the of the man whose name
actually is on this award that I that I
accepted today I would prefer it if
there were no Brian Greenbaum award I
wish there were a Brian Greenbaum still
here he was an award himself to all of
us who knew him and if this were the
world I preferred to live in I wouldn't
be standing here nor would Ted we'd be
sitting with Brian critiquing
everybody's clothes and including mine
and and wishing that there were no such
thing as aids or any of the other
afflictions that have made people like
Brian and my good friend Casey and his
memory I also accept this award
leave us thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]
we're back right now the independent
film community would like to say thank
you to all of the sponsors today so
ladies an gentlemen a round of applause
for Kodak Panavision and Bravo and with
us doing interviews for Bravo is mr.
Roger Ebert a lot of you know him
good huh now what brings you to town
what are you exactly are you doing with
Bravo
well what we're doing is kind of
interesting we are taping this event and
then it's going to be edited down into
segments exactly as long as the
commercial breaks on the Oscars so that
when you're watching the Academy Awards
on Monday night whenever they go to
commercials you go to Bravo and then you
watch the winners and then we interview
I've got Robert Rodriguez right here we
interview the winners and we show scenes
from their clips and our clips from
their movies and it's a good way I think
to draw attention to a wider audience to
what's going on in the independent
community and congratulations
well congratulations again Robert
Rodriguez and we'll be talking to you by
the way Robert do you have a nighttime
gig would you'd like to be a movie
critic or Ron I mean Gene Siskel spot is
up no gene is actually here today so I
think I was doing private gene I'd like
to talk to you about meteor man
you helped it leave the theater like a
meteor are the Hughes brothers still
here have any drive back equipment no
hey I think you have the idea no ladies
doing around applause for even and Cisco
[Applause]
right now it gives me great pleasure to
introduce the president of IFP West mr.
Jonathan wax
[Music]
thank you Robert thank you ladies and
gentlemen
you know the IFP is a strange bird we
kind of know what we're not but we're
not quite sure of what we are I mean we
know we're not a trade union like the ia
or a trade organization like the MPAA
and we're not a guild like the DGA or a
film school like UCLA and we're
certainly not an agency like CAA or a
support group like the AAA although
occasionally we do provide breakdown
service like the triple-a in fact our
effort in our effort to service our
members and speak on behalf of the
independent filmmaking community we do a
little of each last year at this event I
spoke about the need for our voice to be
heard concerning the MPAA rating system
and how seriously flawed it is and how
badly it needs reforming I'm happy to
say that towards the end of last year
the IFP West hosted an all-day
conference attended by an array of
people from across the independent film
spectrum including distributors
exhibitors filmmakers attorneys and
representatives from the guild the
outcome of this discussion is a
hard-nosed carefully worked out proposal
to reform the rating system we're
looking forward to circulating this
document over the next few weeks to get
your input in the hope that as a
community as the independent filmmaking
community we can set about correcting
this objectionable form of corporate
censorship
every year I get asked by the press
whether independent filmmaking is just a
springboard to the major leagues whether
they're independent films are just kind
of rehearsal for the big thing for the
real thing and I suppose that's true for
some individual filmmakers but the point
I want to stress is that independent
filmmakers are not writing second-class
independent filmmaking is a rejection of
mainstream movies it is a howl in the
face of the stupefying predictability of
corporate entertainment independent
films are an alternative to the
mainstream independent films are
alternative films we make films in a
different way we finance them
differently we produce them differently
we budget them differently and we have a
point of view which is deliberately at
odds with the mainstream and these
Spirit Awards here today are not just
some Junior Olympics yearning to be
admitted to the big show the Oscar
Olympics what we are celebrating today
is a different kind of film making films
that are deliberately provocative and
eccentric that take chances and
challenge the prevailing political
cultural and aesthetic conventions now
don't get me wrong I have no illusions
that the attention of the world this
weekend is on the indie Spirit Awards
and not on the Oscars I mean after all
Steven Spielberg didn't name the main
character of Schindler's List Indy
Schindler or spirit Schindler he named
him Oskar Schindler he knew what he was
doing
in the upcoming year the IFP West will
take the first steps towards the
realization of a dream as an
organization we are looking toward the
creation of an independent film center
the core of the center will be a movie
theatre with seven days a week 365 days
a year
we will run American independent films
and films from around the world around
the theater we'll have the offices of
the IFP and other like-minded
organizations production offices an
independent film database perhaps even
some basic production and
post-production facilities it will be a
place where filmmakers can gather and
share amongst their comrades where
filmmaking as a form of cultural and
artistic expression will flourish and be
respected in fact over the entrance of
the independent filmmaking center under
the IFP logo there'll be a sign that
will read independent filmmakers of the
world unite you have nothing to lose but
your change your spare change something
like that we hope that in the months
ahead we can count on your support and
enthusiasm towards the realization of
this dream the independent film center
ladies and gentlemen it's wonderful to
see you all here again this year thank
you for coming and have a great time
[Music]
hi y'all Gary Grossman said that I
couldn't thank anyone because it would
make it sound like a Rotary Club
convention but I'm and I want to thank
responsibly the cocktail party
beforehand wrapped around the room I
also want to thank our incredible
production team tonight co-producers
Gary Grossman and Kathy Bornstein so
yeah they did a great job through hell
and high water they went to produce this
associate producer Robert Foust and
director David Galligan in the set
playing that the set designer and
lighting designer Russell Pyle
if the program is any shorter this year
you can thank them it's because of their
good work I also want to give a special
thanks to the chairperson of a spirit
Awards Committee and the president of
IFP West who gave up a lot of her time
from alpha send all of her personal life
to make this event happen today that's
Kathy main none of us would be here
today without the extraordinary vision
and a hard work of one woman Sondra Shue
Oberg
in 1979 way back then she mapped out a
strategy to support and promote the
American independent film movement you
could still say movement in the 70s she
spent nine months setting up a three-day
conference the first independent film
market and a festival of American
independence and called her creation the
independent feature project she called a
project because she thought it worked
with only it would be finished in a year
or so well it's too bad for you Sondra
because here we are 15 years later with
seven IFP chapters nationwide 6,000
members and the project is far from
finished
saundra nose independent filmmaking from
every angle both in the United States
and abroad her production credits
include Allen barista Rev desange
Northern Lights bill Azhar the Cajun and
waiting for the moon she distributed
Northern Lights herself taking it from
theater to theater she helped found
first-run features one of the first
independent featured one of the first
independent distribution companies and
one that's still in operation today and
as senior vice president of American
Playhouse
she has significantly expanded its reach
beyond the United States she's one of
the people who early on was instrumental
in increasing foreign co-production
co-financing for American independence
people don't know you so well here
Sondra in Los Angeles so I think after
today you're gonna be getting a lot of
phone calls she also created the
American Playhouse abroad to secure
foreign financing for the company's
films but her great growth was seeing
that the fragmented independent film
movement could become stronger if
filmmakers had a means of talking to
each other and a means of sharing
information so it is my pleasure and
honor to present a special spirit award
to the founder of independent feature
project Sondra Schulberg
[Music]
feel a little bit like The Wizard of Oz
probably look like a wizard in this hat
- it's a little disconcerting to have
the curtain pulled back I'm afraid
you're all going to discover that there
isn't some great inspiring figure behind
the curtain but just a lowly lever
puller and I want to first of all say
that the focus on me that dawn so
flatteringly
insisted on is is not accurate of course
I was a catalyst but I was a catalyst
for the energies of people in this room
and of course far beyond this room and
there there is someone here today who
was particularly critical to the
founding of the independent future
project and that's Myles mogul sq who
was then program director of the film
fund who saw the kernel of value in this
first proposal that Steve wax and I
wrote and encouraged us it helped shape
it and eventually made a home for the
independent feature project at the film
fund in New York when I was asked to
come and receive this award and give
people some of the background of the IFP
I unpacked the archives which I hadn't
looked at in 15 years and I did find a
few treasures like for instance the
one-page proposal for the first Los
Angeles office of the IFP with a budget
that amounts to less than a I think five
lunch tables here and which very humbly
proposed that the National Board which
we had at that time be able to veto the
selection of the first paid staff person
of course after the first la seminar
which was brilliantly organized by the
inimitable Greg Nava anatomists Steve
wax who was part of it
Barbara Blum Edlund ler Victoria Wozniak
David Morris and probably many other
of you who are here that humility went
out the window and after that it was
excuse me but like in New York and we'll
we'll be fine on our own and as a result
of that determination and independence
as Don said there now autonomous I FPS
around the country the IFP was started
by a band of outsiders and we were we
were arrogant I think in our in our
protest there was a element of moral
superiority and now that we're 15 years
old
some of us bit older than that in fact
it's I think in our maturity we can sort
of face the hard questions it's I I
spend part of every year in Europe and I
can tell you that American culture is
inexorably marching its way across the
world and I feel that we have a
responsibility as independence knowing
that films do open people's hearts and
minds to really ask ourselves what we're
opening those hearts and minds to I
think that audiences need entertainment
that's nourishing that's devoid of
toxins that leaves you inspired and
strong and above all clear-headed so
that we can face the challenges of this
increasingly complicated world with
increasingly fewer resources and so that
we can help bring about a peaceful
collaboration among all the peoples and
also the animals of the planet if we
could redefine independent in this as
the millennium approaches to mean that
then I would be very proud to continue
calling myself an independent thank you
very much
[Music]
what about it lining for the keys for
your truck last month I didn't say okay
you didn't say okay she said okay what
are we doing here singing Parliament I
gotta go
Jeff you know what it takes to run that
truck of yours do you have any idea what
a teenager's insurance cost do you know
what a promise is what from mom promised
me she 2bath me 50 bucks why bother with
the truth exactly what to do with it
smooth there's no meaning in this house
I'm not going with you I'm yelling it
lower your voice Jeff act like a human
being that's right your mother and you
apologize to me along now you're both
liars what you watch what you're saying
so I have until I get to the bank
I'll leave time with mrs. Valdez and I
think I got ten okay it's okay dad
around the bus to have an accident
the director of little Nikita Richard
Benjamin
[Music]
and an honor to be here in this room
with so many creative and talented
people I thought that I had discovered
River Phoenix I also thought when I was
a kid I discovered James Dean and Marlon
Brando
when river came into my office something
happened and there was a connection and
I thought I was the only one who saw
that connection I asked him if he wanted
to read for the part although I thought
to myself it doesn't make any difference
to me anymore whether he can read or not
this kid has got to be in this movie
when I cast a movie I cast for soul who
the person is and I could see River soul
there was nothing between me and him I
thought that I was the only one and saw
that of course everyone saw it when I
went to Sidney Poitier's house and asked
him to be in the movie and he knew a
river was in it he said well not only do
I like the project but I have to be in
it there's a 4-foot poster of River in
my daughter's room when we started
shooting the movie wherever we were at
night at 4:00 in the morning in the
middle of the afternoon
nowhere people came around now they were
usually girl people they're all about
sixteen or so but they would come out of
everywhere
a connection with his generation you
know you can be an actor in the movies
and you can actor brains out and it
doesn't mean anything unless that
chemical thing is there and with River
it was there in the scene that you saw
which is a scene about family with
Richard Jenkins and Caroline Carver
playing his parents river talks about
the truth and one of the wonderful
things of working with River was that he
was a truth machine when something
didn't work it and he couldn't do it I
knew that the thing wasn't right if he
couldn't do it because there was nothing
inside of him that could fake he could
not do it and some of you know in this
room what happens between actors and a
director in making a movie becomes
really a love affair and I loved this
kid this child he was 15 and became 16
on that movie and I thought to myself
the performances that are to come the
movies that are to come the things we
are going to see over our lifetime of
this boy this man will be astounding and
that was not to be somebody said the
tragedy is the loss of great potential
and it was a tragedy that we won't see
those performances maybe we all want
they will see them I was doing one scene
I don't know where we were in the middle
of the night somewhere and I it was with
Sidney and I was pushing River I knew
there was more there and I pushed him
then it was better and then I pushed him
again and it was good it was really good
it was the kind to take you to walk away
from and he went like this to me just
very quietly seconds and I said sure and
then he went into that other thing and
after that take Sydney came over to me
and he said that boy just gave you a
gift and I believe he gave all of us a
gift and I'll miss him and I love him
Thanks I'm gonna bring out to be
presenters I'm really excited about he
was in a film and he was absolutely
brilliant brilliant brilliant brilliant
called naked and she is my favorite
comedian actress please welcome mr.
David Thewlis and Sandra Bernhard
[Music]
in architecture foundations provide the
necessary support for buildings unless
of course it's 4:30 in the morning and
you're running screaming out of your
house in writing subtext provides the
underbelly for a character and in acting
supporting roles provide the layers
crucial to a film's construct giving it
the edges and shapes to round out its
character and story the nominees for
Best Supporting male are david chung for
the ballad of little joe Tate Donovan
for inside monkey settlin tart filled
for Ruby in paradise Edward Furlong for
American heart and Christopher Lloyd for
20 books and the winner is Christopher
Lloyd
I'm looking for a fun what do you want
to rob this place with you don't unless
you're prepared to shoot 30 witnesses
I'm more interested in easy places gas
station Christopher Lloyd is an Aries
shooting a film can be here so we accept
the world the nominees for Best
Supporting female are Lara Flynn Boyle
equinox
all the Gua the wedding banquets
lucinda Jenny American Heart Julianne
Moore shortcuts and Lili Taylor
household sinks and the winner is
Lili Taylor my business to read human
nature a minute I saw you at that
discussion group I said there's a girl I
wish I did
well everybody shined us on Lily
couldn't be with us today we accept this
award on her behalf thank you
[Music]
they're all on location no but I know if
they were here they would have ladies
and gentlemen I says here getting ready
for a Big Mac attack
so please welcome if you would mr. John
tour tour
[Music]
thank you the world of Hollywood all too
often forget that films not just a
commercial endeavor but can be filled
with visual perceptions and drama in
memory and in the spirit of the great
filmmaker John Cassavetes this award
honors maverick filmmakers whose work
has significantly extended the
possibilities of film this year the IFP
West has chosen Jim Jarmusch as the
recipient
[Applause]
I've seen that guy before I think didn't
he like terrorize Jodie Foster and then
become a construction work John
Cassavetes among more than anyone else I
think really understood that a film is
never made by one person and it's a film
making us a series of collaborations on
on every level I love the way that John
Cassavetes and his amazing collaborators
made their films and I'm very proud to
accept this award on on behalf of all
the amazing people that I've had the
good luck to work with some of whom are
even here today so I'm not real good at
the whole awards the idea of awards but
I'm very happy to accept that this one
and at first I was kind of hesitant to
come to accept the award simply because
I thought it it felt a little
pretentious or presumptuous on my part
to get an award with John Cassavetes
name on it but I remember a quote that I
memorized quite a few years ago after
seeing a documentary on the making of
love streams where in which John
Cassavetes had said I think that I think
filmmakers should be aware that they
don't know anything and at least in that
on that level I felt like I was at least
qualified as a filmmaker
so again on behalf of all the people
that I've had the great fortune to work
with I thank you for them for this award
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
are you guys having a good time even
those of you that lost you still winners
today I know that's a cliche but it's
true to be here so give yourselves a
round of applause before we present the
next Award for Best Foreign Film there
was a foreign film I saw the other day
that really affected me as a filmmaker
and I'd like to share with you a few
scenes from this French film by
jean-claude bosons Otilia was like young
[Music]
is a tragic story create a happy I
cannot do that and have a nice day
circle tell a muscle tear I was lost I
was confused
super fill em up some tears
flipsie 50l I didn't know where to turn
should open him up too dear
I was in search of the green light
shackleton a marsupial
then I saw a poster i FB let's go down
Jonathan wax I met this man gentleman
wax he introduced me to other filmmakers
a filmmaker who had done a film for
$7,000 a filmmaker who had done a film
on credit cards he was so handsome so
strong so intelligent he needed a 20
pitch a deal she'll tell him I'll sit
there I discovered who I was with their
small budgets our small crews
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen here to present the
best foreign film he recently appeared
in the get away and she was last year
Spirit Award winner for passion fish
please welcome miss alfre woodard and
mr. Michael Matson
[Music]
thank you
unlike the studios whose major deity is
the box office Indies devote themselves
to creative risk as so boldly delivered
in the exuberant gender frolic Orlando
the character studies social
observations is acutely witnessed in the
film naked 2 teaching us to fight for
our rights and perhaps discover
ourselves as in the exquisitely told
story of kichu - the penetrating passion
portrayed through the silent landscape
of emotions and I can't believe they
said in the piano and by nourishing our
hearts and souls with the magic realism
of Like Water for Chocolate the nominees
for best foreign film are like water for
chocolate Alphonso
[Applause]
naked director might leave
Orlando director Sally Potter
[Applause]
the piano director Jane Campion
the story of kichu director zhang amoun
[Applause]
and the winner is
a piano
[Applause]
accepting the award for Jane Campion is
producer Jan Chapman
thank you I'm really glad I flew in this
morning
look it's just great to win an
Independent Spirit Award because if
there's one expression that describes
where Jane and I made the piano that's
it I don't think we realized at the time
how unusual it was to be able to make
the screenplay that you wanted to to
cast the people that you wanted to and
to have final cut and you know we did it
and I find it completely affirming that
we did it and I think it's something for
all of us to believe in you can make
films the way you want to of course
there are a few people who helped us
Francis wig from CB DeMille who was a
man who in his later years tell in love
with the cinema and and left us alone at
the bottom of the world and you see own
in Australia to make this film a cast
and crew who stood by us all the way and
really believed in Jane's original
vision represented today by this
stupendous miss Holly Hunter and by a
cinematographer Stuart Ryberg and also
by some independent distributors Harvey
and Bob Weinstein Miramax Films who
we've put up with Jane and I wanted to
collaborate even during the distribution
process without guys like that you can't
make films like ours thank you very much
[Music]
the next presenters well he lights your
fire she told you what's love got to do
with it please welcome mr. Val Kilmer
and Miss Angela Bassett
[Music]
thanks for inviting us what's rare
within the studio system is abundant
among the independence rolls in the
category of best female lead all share a
common theme the search for self
acceptance in their feminine selves and
a continuing struggle to be heard and
understood the nominees for best female
lead are susie amos the palette of the
job may chin the wedding banquet are ian
johnson just another girl on the IRT
Ashley Judd
Emma Thompson much ado about nothing
and the winner is Ashley judge what is
your name
kissing would be Liga Singh
accepting the award for Ashley Judd is
Todd field unfortunately Ashley couldn't
be here she's doing a play in New York
right now but I know there's some people
that she'd like to thank first of all
Victor Nunez for his courage and
relentless pursuit for the delicious
moment Keith Crofford our producer for
stretching every penny and not letting
any of us ever feel it and especially
Michelle Stern who's always been a
constant support and friend and finally
to all the members of the AFP thank you
very much
[Music]
the nominees for best male lead show men
at a variety of crossroads their
performances are powerful renderings of
ordinary men who struggles open up us to
greater compassion the nominees for best
male lead are Jeff Bridges American
Heart Vincent I hope I get this right
Donofrio household Saints Mitchell
Lichtenstein the wedding banquet Matthew
Modine equinox
[Applause]
and tieran turner menace to society and
the winner is Jeff Bridges I know what
it's like your first time they can break
your heart but you got to remember
you're a good-looking kid you got my
looks you got to learn to keep your
heart babe let them lose their as you
keep yours that's a trick of being a
heartbreaker
[Applause]
thank you wow this is a very special
part for me it's such a good time
working on this movie especially because
it was an independent film you know we
we didn't have to compromise on our
vision we made the film that we set out
to make and that was really important to
all of us involved another reason that
this was such a gratifying experience
for me it was a chance to shed some
light on a part of our society that
doesn't get the light shone on it too
often both politically and and in in the
movies and that's the the part of us
that that lived below the poverty line
there's 36 million of us that are living
below the poverty line now 15 million of
us are kids that's about one in five of
our children so it was great to make a
film like this one for that reason I'd
especially like to thank Martin Bell
they're doing such a brilliant job in
directing this film he had such an
inclusive spirit and the tone that he
said was just was just terrific to work
with and Peter Silverman for running
such a brilliant screenplay
Jim begged on us for making it look so
so right just hitting the right tone on
that Jim wherever you are man it was
beautiful my my partners Eddie furlong
and CIN to Jenny who did such a great
job thank you guys
[Applause]
I'd like to give a special thanks to
Eddie bunker who is my technical adviser
on the on the movie I don't know if he's
here tonight but he was God so
inspirational he always kept us on track
to keep it authentic and I thank him for
that let me get my card out here cuz I'm
gonna forget somebody and Dubonnet
yeah and world films she was right there
from the beginning to the end and you
know she inspired us so much and had
such faith in us and thanks for that in
Kerry Brokaw like to thank him and
having new pictures neill coningsburgh
of Roz Heller my co-producers Rona
Wallace with live entertainment
Bob Bernie and Jonathan Dana
Tritan pictures I especially like to
thank Mary Ellen mark who was a producer
on the film but she also sourced the
project she about 15 years ago she did a
layout for Life magazine about kids
living on the street in Seattle and
that's that's what this film was was all
about and it came from really Mary for
Mary oh and so thank you for that Mary
Ellen and Rick Necedah and Jonathan
Weiss Cole I'd like to thank them and my
wife and my kids for supporting me
during this this adventure and my mother
and my father and my brother beau who
taught me how to how to act how to do it
and the man upstairs glory be to God and
you folks it if IFP thank you very much
this really means a lot to me thank you
[Music]
actor and director mr. Sean Penn
I was glad to hear that the guy who made
that film the clip was from he's going
back to Miramax so he's got a studio
chief looks at him with two eyes at the
same time some of you know what I'm
talking about I like to make things easy
on myself so I tend to break films and
filmmakers down into two categories
those who assume that an audience has no
imagination of dreams of their own and
therefore contrived dreams and theories
of imagination for them and those who
find a structure in which to share their
dreams and while the particulars may be
different the soul is the same and gives
us a sense around alone I've known the
keynote speaker for a while but the
anecdote that comes to mind is when he
started quoting Hamlet four o'clock in
the morning Shelburne hotel in Dublin
after we'd had a and the pints of
Guinness where if you rearrange those
monitors there a little bit that's where
I was well he didn't just quote Hamlet
he did the whole fucking play a great
drinker and that and a touched sharer
Jim Sheridan
[Music]
I feel like I'm in Las Vegas or
something when I was on the film John
Baker who played the IRA man who was a
blues playing harmonica player came up
to me on the first day and he said feel
my heart
that's what mine's going like now boom
boom boom and he said I'm so nervous
well I'm like that within a week he was
saying Jim could I say it this way and
then about a week later he was saying
could you get that actor to say it like
this but I was gonna come up here and
prepare a speech and all that and I
decided I kind of improvise because a
lot of the times on the film I might do
that just throw away the script and I
thought I'd throw myself to the Lions
with the hope that you just listen and
Terry George's promised me sitting down
there who wrote this in the name of the
Father with me that he'd jump up and did
hey there Terry wave
well terry has promised me that if I'm
going on too long he's gonna stand on
the chair and show hey you're on too
long I I thought I tell you basically I
decided to pitch the next film I'm gonna
make to the room and see if anybody
likes it okay here's how it starts I'm
in Ireland running a theater and we put
on a gay sweatshop play and the reviews
say worse than necrophilia they take
away our grants and I say fuck it I'm
over here so I say to find my wife and
the two kids come on let's go we go to
the States but I had a friend in Toronto
who ran a theater so I went there and
for a little bit and then I'm Patrick
stay at the side come down to America to
the Irish Arts Center and we drove down
and I kept saying the front you know
keep going faster faster because we
wanted to get there you know early the
kids were fed up driving and we were
arrested about midnight taken to court
and the judge was pretty pissed off
because he was woken by the two police
men and he find us $40 so we reached an
air pocket we 26 Canadian and 13
American and he said you have to have 40
and we didn't have it genuinely so one
of the policemen put them in four
quarters and the judge asked me if I put
it down I said no so he said the
policeman said yes he did I saw him so
he said well and I was afraid to say I
did because I thought um I get arrested
for perjury so the judge then said well
I need a witness and the other policeman
said well I saw so the judge took the
quarter and let us go at which point I
said to the two cops you know how do we
pay the tolls and they gave us ten
dollars and we drove on to New York
okay so Kota eight nine years later and
I'm in a place getting a tuxedo for the
Oscars and Nold Pearson's wit me and he
says you better write a speech and I
said not be bad look of a road of speech
so we're walking back along Santa Santa
Monica Boulevard and we're going past
rage and I hear oh my god Jim so I look
around and there's this guy called
Romero and he's a six foot four black
guy and he grabs my suit he goes you
made it you made it look at the fucking
label and he's looking at the label of
my suit then he opens his own suit and
says look at I made it too and what it
turns out is that he lived in the same
house as us in New York and he was a
painter and he used to put his paintings
on the subway he was crazy you know he'd
take a photograph of them and put them
on the subway and Bob Dylan was walking
along and he saw this painting and he
said get me that for the cover of my
album so six months later they're gonna
do the cover of the album and they've
all the artwork and they don't have this
paint and so Dylan says find it and they
do a long search and they find her mayor
when they ring him and they say hi Bob
Dylan once you do the cover of his new
album and he says go fuck yourself and
hangs up and eventually he they rang him
back and he did the cover of oh mercy
and he said to me you know that house
was blessed we lived in it was blessed
you made it I made it
Joey jumped off the back roof Sandra is
an opera singer Billy died of AIDS and
everybody dieter died or was quite
successful now I spend seven years than
in New York basically trying to do one
thing which was to get a review from the
New York Times and we put on six shows a
year for seven years and we didn't get
any reviews except the one show we moved
which you know we raised 110
dollars to move it we tangoed reviews
and xi was the New York Times and
basically after like years and years of
doing this I said look you can't just be
dependent I'm gonna organization or I
don't even know if it's their fault that
they have in a monopoly over to you
there but I decided to write a script a
film script and I just started on my
left foot and it was as simple as that
and I think that's I mean it's an
important thing to say that if you get a
monopoly in any area whether it's
Studios money whatever and even it's
dangerous to have films that you know
overrun Europe because in the end
monopolies don't work and I think it's
very important to independent filmmakers
get the money wherever they can it's
easier in Europe in many ways and you
know when we did my left foot the
amazing thing was we just had no
interference we raised the money from TV
about six months before I came back to
do it my kid I had these shoes and they
had holes in them you know and I didn't
know so much and then it snowed once I'm
back at home and I was wringing my socks
out and I was really annoyed and my kid
Karason was watching me and I remember
because she for Christmas she bought me
a pair of galoshes
but these galoshes used to soak in the
snow because they were so he's too big
so that was my last memory of just going
back and doing the film and then it
opened in Ireland in England and it was
kind of mine her head and Harvey
Weinstein got it and he really believed
it and I remember they met me wouldíve
and he said you know I love this film my
wife loves the film my brother loves the
film we're gonna push it and then I was
under set in the field looking off we
went straight into that and I saw
pauline kael review and you know things
just totally changed my life changed and
I actually would go into stores then you
know and boy like a jacket and for the
first time I you know I actually could
look at the material you know whether
it's like
Lenin or whatever because before that
you just look at price tags that's what
everybody out there does so I realized
that vision or whatever you call it is
an internal change and that's what we
have to do to the audience's give them
the chance to see in that way okay the
only other I'll give you one of their
story I don't know what it means see
their spirit Ward here imagine that's a
church where he was a kid right so the
church was here the top of the W is the
priests house the top of this door is
the school I went to and there the
relative Heights believe me and this is
my own houses the lodging house and this
mic here is the TV area and my father's
pond table and him and my uncle are
working on the TV and this is a day in
which when I look out there it's snowing
and when I look at my feet it's not and
I'll try and explain why that happens I
won't take you long my father's trying
to turn the aerial towards England to
find out where England is and he's
arguing my uncle Huseyin England's over
there my father say no it's over here my
father saying doesn't the Liffey flow
east that's where England is East my
uncle saying the Liffey goes in a bloody
circle like that out to sea
so they're twisted and torn in this
aerial and the other uncle's on a ladder
and he's looking at the television and
he just keeps saying it's snow snow snow
all you have a snow so eventually my
uncle Jim said to my father the reason
you can't get reception is the church is
blocking the signal and this is actually
a true story the church was blocking the
signal so the signal from England used
to hit the church bounced oh and reform
though five houses down here where the
reception was quite good but in our host
the reception was bad and it was like
you know you'd get the horizontal hold
would go on the vertical hold and it
would become snowy and you could barely
see
picture and yet it was still television
so we used to have to listen to them we
had to listen to the picture of you know
what I mean so at that point Irish
television came in over here bypassed
the church and Ireland changed and I
think in many ways it was a result of
television and changes like that and
that's how powerful it is but it's also
dangerous in that it does bypass the
church or whatever and knocks down the
Berlin wall it causes and film is part
of that and the images that we have in
the world that come from here and here
you do create the way people see the
world and I think it's very important
and it's very important that the huge
high-rise buildings were all the money
don't just put their message out that
the money is all important the money is
not all important it's the spirit of the
thing that's important okay thank you Oh
have you guys having a good time and
again all the let's give a round of
applause again for all the nominees all
the nominees when he was talking a few
minutes ago it's it's everything that he
was saying is it's so real in terms of
movies and images and when I think about
the power of movies walking into a movie
theater and it can change the way you
feel make you feel different and the
fact that movies around forever it's
like a piece of history you know I mean
everything must change nothing stays the
same well that's the way of time
[Music]
nothing and no one goes unchanged
unchanged the young become the no it's
hard to believe I used to be I used to
be young man yeah I was a filmmaker yeah
I made movies I was a independent
filmmaker yeah yeah we we were the real
voice of Hollywood yeah no we really
were I mean I mean you know shorty ends
little occasions no crew we made the
real movies yeah and I used to be a
comedian to tell you joke okay I tell
you I tell you I tell I tell you I tell
you I tell you joke what does a man with
a 12-inch penis have for breakfast you
don't know you don't know I'll tell you
this morning I had toast
juice and eggs I'll tell you another one
I did another one blind man said to his
wife if you want to make love to me just
yank on my thing one time for yes if you
don't want to make love to me Yanko my
thing
50 times for no I used to be a comedian
and this is he did this in the 90s I did
a film on credit card alone oh yeah yeah
and then I was in well well three yeah I
was in well well three they dropped that
bomb now everybody's gray no black no
white no red no yellow just gray light
gray and dark gray don't nothin change
people still prejudiced people still
prejudiced just the other day there's
light gray man call me aggregor
I said no call me no damn Gregor I got
on the phone when I called the
n-double-a-cp
yeah but I was proud yeah I'm a member
today they got to cure the AIDS remember
that yeah I remember that day they found
the cure but that ain't nothing I'd hate
to catch that nuclear disease I got out
there now make all that noise yeah yeah
but one day it's gonna change that's why
I always felt movies was away it was
like that white boy wrote a song you
know the white boy - one that guy killed
he was in that insect group lemon-lime
in linen John Lennon you might say then
I'm a dreamer but I'm not the only one
hope someday you'll come and join us and
the world
[Music]
thank you these next presenters he will
be seen in the new movie no escape for
Savoy pitchers and Karina Karina for a
New Line Cinema she was the winner of
the 1993 National Society of Film
Critics Award for Best Supporting
Actress for her role in short cuts
please welcome mr. Ray Liotta and Miss
madeleine stowe
[Music]
directors use their life experiences to
connect us to the ordinary physical
world through the expression of film
directors life experiences then are a
way of seeing and then seeing again the
connection between ourselves and the
world we live in the nominees for Best
Director are Robert Altman shortcuts
angly the wedding banquet
[Applause]
Victor Nunez Ruby in paradise Robert
Rodriguez Regas excuse me
el Mariachi and John Tudor Oh Mac
and the winner is Robert Altman quick
it's too quick for me what they won't do
alone
do you I used to be fooling up married I
would if we'd stop fooling around I kind
of like it what about you Robert Altman
is shooting in France we accept this
award on his
[Applause]
[Music]
all right this next presenter she
embodies the beliefs of the independence
unafraid to follow her heart fearless of
challenges capable of diverse talents
please welcome Miss Holly Hunter
[Music]
hi good afternoon it's nice to be here
the nominees for Best Feature are
Equinox executive producers Nicholas
Tilly honest
Sid cap sandy Stern producer David
blocker much ado about nothing
producers Stephen Evans David Parfitt
Kenneth Branagh
Ruby and paradise producer Sam Gowen and
Keith Crofford and shortcuts executive
producer Scott Bushnell producer Carrie
Brokaw in the wedding banquet executive
producer Zhang Feng cheese producers
James Shamus Ted hope and Angley and the
winner is shortcuts
[Applause]
honey we've been sleeping Yanks thanks
this was a very difficult film to make
not that every other film that's been
talked about today isn't in fact they
all are this was ten stories 22 actors
the child's death the earthquake
alcoholism extramarital sex trout
fishing a clown phone sex a dead body
malathion three hours and ending the
Griffin mill would have never approved
we had to do it I want to acknowledge
all the actors that made it possible
that brought an extraordinary truth to
every moment the crew Frank bar height
and Bob Altman for creating a phenomenal
script Raymond Carver Tess Gallagher
Scott Bushnell and most of all I want to
thank Bob Altman the man who made it all
possible
they made it and the man who made it
really fun Thanks
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen I just want to say
thank you again to the sponsors Bravo
Kodak Panavision and the sponsor of the
cocktail-hour entertainment weekly'
thank you very much for coming out see
you next year continue to support IFP
West thank you
[Music]